this is a request for video submissions
for potential inclusion into a solo
podcast episode about the war in ukraine
and future episodes on other topics see
the link in the description for more
details
i would like to hear your story your
perspectives or your thoughts and
questions you might like me to include
in an episode and perhaps hear me
comment on
i'm particularly interested in stories
from people whose life is deeply
affected by the event in question for
example for the war in ukraine i would
like to hear from people in ukraine
russia and surrounding regions
from soldiers to refugees
but i would also like to hear the
stories and perspectives from people in
china india and the rest of the world i
want to hear both about what weighs
heavy on your heart and about what gives
you strength and hope
i may leave this website up for a long
time so this is not just about the war
in ukraine this is also about our life
on earth together
both people with a platform and without
are welcome
in the form you fill out you can specify
whether you want just the audio to be
included or both the audio and video
it is very important to me that you
deeply consider whether you want that
video or audio to be heard potentially
by a very large number of people
only send this if you're 100 sure that
it is something you're okay for me to
include in the podcast
i'm first and foremost concerned about
your safety but also
that a year from now 10 years from now
for the rest of your life it is
something you're proud of of having to
be on the internet and part of this
podcast
i'm not sure whether this idea will work
but i am sure that i want to keep trying
in whatever way possible to listen to
the stories of real human beings no
matter who they are where they come from
or how they see and experience the world
if we do not include your story
perspective or question i still send you
my love and gratitude for taking the
time to tell it
if we do include your story i will be
sure to try to honor your voice as best
as i can
thank you for your time and your support
i love you all
you